so but don't do that with your hands
keep your hands down today what's the
one for hands down today came in hot
well because yourselves don't call me
back
don't call me if your bats gonna fight
with a bum now hold on okay I got a lot
to lose you know that dude but I had a
temper and bumped hey leave me homes are
gonna bum they're gonna bum bums are
gonna bug bought the bum cape young guy
use it harder than me young bum a young
bum taller than me young dumb let's go
let's use the proper let's not be
offensive with bomb let's call me hobo a
young ho hobos betters hobo worse hope
or bum either way what's the correct
gentleman who has a the gentleman who
has a major problem with alcohol and
hasn't gotten his life together at 38 35
it's a problem young you're taller than
me younger there's a woman who can't
catch her breath and she's on the phone
right outside and I go because I'm Good
Samaritan say below and guidance a
backhoe and captain say well some even
call me a bit of a hero
maybe the skinny hero I'm not heard that
that's in the media not captain save a
drunk also yeah keep your nose out of
other people's business
there's a lady there's a lady in
distress okay so daddy's instinct we
should buy a protect not sure was the
shadow is it every bit of 16 I can keep
on keeping on my god I'll pull over fix
your tire of course but I come running
up I go you okay honey and she's got her
bags on the ground I immediately sent
something's wrong really bags are on the
ground the shoes crying he's crying but
she's not crying huh and she goes I'm an
alcoholic I drank and my son kicked me
out okay a lot of info just my son comes
down he's a guy in a tie and a nice guy
he's already guys backpack came home
from work obviously goes you're not
gonna be around my child drinking I told
you I'd fly you down here if you drink
I'll take you out yeah so he's at that
point with her you have to get out no
you can't be around the mom the hobo
said Dirk she's gonna go yeah I told you
yeah in a hope o / BOM / person with a
problem I don't know about Susan is
there Creek Twitter transient right
transient no come on hey we gotta quit
please press ok how's it out of this one
of God's children who just has a problem
with alcohol
whoa I'm sure that doesn't work a fallen
angel a fallen angel with bloodshot eyes
eyes at six foot two and a whole lot of
them a lot among in the mouth ah misfit
a homeless misfit with a lot of Hmong in
the mouth Hmong now we live like a white
paste it's a good sale Jared see what a
camel choose wouldn't want a camel or
cows blood
yeah as cud really builds up he's got
cud
yeah it really builds up he's a cub
mouth cool we cool he's a cud mouth and
he goes hey what are you doing that
woman get away from her and even comes
over with a huge bottle of Jack with a
neck that's the stick is my wrist okay
the neck of the bottle yeah like my leg
hood think of my [ __ ] oh and when it's
fully and hot okay okay not getting your
hand around it though right so so he
comes over he's captain save-a-ho - yeah
and I see that he's walking towards I'm
like he's gonna hit the guy with the
bottle and I go wow I go hey I go
alright cuz he walks by me go stay the
[ __ ] out of this you know he turns on me
now he turns on me almost again a
homeless now they put their nose in
everything yep he turns they have
nothing to do so they're looking for
some sort of entertainment you're right
now now I don't know if you know this
the other day I was on stage I was
moving woman said do you train or
something in martial arts and and what
did I say Brennan asked me be the woman
oh my god do you train I am our life now
I have makes me upset and I know now ask
me what oh my god in what and pretty
much everything okay what's very general
I don't believe you I know but you
should have said UFC I know but just
like UFC to get your [ __ ] suck ha
I trained a new trait in UFC train
there's nothing worse UFC oh wow that's
not a format out in UFC so it says train
you I train in UFC people say all the
time
what are you trained UFC that's well
that's like saying woody trained NFL
well that's not a sport is it did I give
you my coffee where's my that was my
gosh I gave that to you right not here
and you poured it in it yeah no you just
took my cross
gonna fight the bump I thought you give
it to me to sip on now as I got my own
coffee because what happened out I take
I don't mind I got you this I knew you
wanted this front panel mill this is
from funnel but when your coffees at I
just thought I thought I mistook a bet
I'd be sure yeah well now cuz your luck
cuz that's better cuz that's funnel mill
admit that final Mills better than any
coffee their cold brew it's it's nice
their cold Brews nice yeah so I'm better
black rifle but it's nice I understand I
understand but I'm saying in the me
I understand
and you're right and you're right
right so you so bums are gonna bum do
you know so the Bom Bom startled for you
to have no business being there right
they're gonna fight each other right Bom
Bom starts moving toward guns bodied up
though he bounced bodied up I'm jealous
of the bums when the shredded they don't
need much yeah so jealous now if you're
a study of the human form and you were
if you were to if you are a student of
the human form of your student movement
yeah if you were Ito portal oh you'd say
yeah what a rev Conor McGregor's well
then you know you were fired but yeah
okay whatever he would he would go woof
I noticed that you put your weight on
your back foot
that was impressive did you ready to go
I'm like you're loading up my heel came
up we called the rattlesnake yeah you're
cocky guy swings the bottle I [ __ ]
see you slept before huh I come back
bang I bring a hug him a two-piece Boop
he goes like that I go Babu opera head
he pulls a knife a sort of machete a
large nut is that my jet this was right
outside here this was outside weird you
called me and I looked out there I just
saw an older black man and you stalking
and I saw this is a white he's a white
this out they were both both people were
whiteness that to be meant they're both
Caucasian okay woman was Caucasian and
the London Scout Cajon the summers [ __ ]
is the bum the hobo one of God's fallen
angels was Caucasian
oh wow he pulled in my jet I I was like
and I go I go hell up in here now you're
hurting my feelings I said oh wow yeah I
go now you're hurt my feelings in here
too you nasty and I and I and I have a
tough
my leaving they slew him he's dead he's
out front
oh wow but he's not out front because I
cut this is gross so any reader if
anybody was listening she denied her I
chopped him anything reading this
transfer please skip ahead duly noted
give it I chopped him up and I pushed
him into the storm drain so dude he's
now with penny wise thank God you made
it dude thank it bad barely
yeah so the early problem maybe the part
wood that my chair and the fighting is
maybe a bum recognize from Joker I was
hoping it was like oh my god you're the
Joker
and you thought he's being hostile and
killed him I got somebody view like dude
loved your camión the Joker then I had
good friends going I thought I heard
your voice bros right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue oh good what's
gonna happen what are you gonna do use
some of that boxing you've been doing
[Laughter]